All right, I think we got some highlights of this guy like springing
out about this. Let's see here
um or of Cardi as well as whether or not he disclosed the image
to ABMC again. How are you going to do discovery on my end for
this ABMC? This is your witness. You should have the information
because you yourself said you deleted this and archived it and
you are supposed to be the source of this evidence probably.
Like if I had to guess, he literally deleted the evidence from
the joint record. And I assume you can't just delete evidence
from the joint record, this thing that's supposed to be your
unimpeachable record, and then never provide the actual record
of your communications, right?
Am I crazy?
Why would that be the case that you can just delete? You can
delete a bunch of evidence and you go, "Well, I deleted it because
I wanted to protect her privacy, but also I won't actually provide
any of the evidence of these logs." That seems bizarre to me,
right? And he's saying, "Oh, go ask Abby MC for her logs." And
it's like, "Bro, you know, you deleted your side of those logs."
Yeah, well, bragging to have kept it archived. Yeah, that seems
like talking out of both sides of your mouth. No. Wouldn't that
be very concerning to people that he said, "Oh, well, the reason
I deleted it was because I archived it and now I have it for
evidence for the court case." And he goes, "But you you should
ask Abby with the deleted logs." That's funny. What are you hoping
to discover from me? Why? This is your It's your witness. Why
are you asking me about it? What the Yet discovery in this matter
is far from complete. And the evidence relied on by defendant
to support argument is not reliable and cannot be authenticated.
Pliff cannot fairly be required to meet her burden of proof without
the opportunity to complete discovery.
>> You guys rule 56 presumes that the parties posing summer
judgement had a fair chance to complete discovery. Um blah blah
blah.
>> Okay. I
like I I don't know where he's I don't understand that contention
there. I understand why you have to signal that to DG to try
to paint yourself as a victim, but I don't understand that contention.
you've deleted their side of the record.
You say you archived it and you go, "Well, why do you want my
side of it? Why would you why would you have any right to my
side of it?" Well, because you deleted that stuff. And the whole
way you like avoid spoliation arguments is by providing that
record, right? That's like the joint record. Otherwise, I I think
he would have deleted it after being aware of the lawsuit. And
that is literally spoliation. If he's not if he's deleted something
in a joint record after being notified not to and he says, "Well,
I'm allowed to do that to protect my privacy." Then I don't see
how you could say, "Well, I'm allowed to do that to protect my
privacy, but I'm not going to provide those records to them."
Is that not totally broken thinking? I I don't know how you could
possibly support that, but maybe Hey, maybe I'm crazy. Seems
like completely broken thinking. Very interesting.
Okay. Why are they doing this to me? Why are they doing this
to me? >> My assumption is they're just trying to make
this claim so that they can push this case out for as long as
they possibly want. But like
hold on. Discovery closes December 16th, 2025.
C order ECF23, but it's still it is still in early stages.
Written discovery is ongoing and depositions have not yet been
conducted. Written discovery only began after the court granted
plaintiff's protective order on September 2nd. Right. So as a
part of the preliminary injunction, they also filed a protective
order and that was only granted in September. So they were basically
waiting to try to file evidence and do depositions because they
didn't want to expose people's identities. Oh, and he's going
to like totally leave that out, right? He's going to be he's
going to totally leave that out. His propensity for like doxing
people obviously leading to them going, "Oh, yeah, well, we probably
do have to protect these people." Huh. Maybe he'll say that.
Maybe he'll say maybe he'll be very fair and he'll say, "You
know, I have been, you know, I've been on a doxing like spree
recently, so you know, it kind of makes sense that they had to
wait for their protective orders >> more or less and turn
over everything they've asked for. They keep asking for like
broader and broader things. Like I don't remember if I said this
before, but at one point in the early stages of this case, they
were saying that they wanted every single image and video that
I'd sent and received over the past 5 years. That's how broad
that they they thought they could do like their discovery. This
is just like a job. I was like, "This is never happening. You're
out of your mind." Um,
so there they're
the best part of this is going to be if um
the best part of this would be if somebody with like a very clear
case here comes forward. All right, I know people have way clearer
cases.
If one of those people with a clear case comes forward and files
a civil suit, if this were to be dismissed and he's celebrating
and he gets hit with like a civil suit for Molina or something,
that would just be very funny to me. It would just be very, very
funny. >> They're committed to this idea that, oh, no,
no, no. We're still We're still just starting. Uh they're still
just starting discovery. Somebody in chat said they want the
case to go in front of a jury. I've seen it in my dreams. Uh
I don't think they do. I think they just want to drag it out
for as long as possible. I would be surprised if they really
want it to go in front of a jury. Maybe. Why?
Hey, hold on. They just want to drag it out for as long as possible.
So they just want to spend money to hurt him. That's like where
he's at is the only way they could do this is if they want to
spend money just to hurt him only.
It's not that he did something wrong. It's not that he's been
a total
subhuman piece of [__] to a ton of people he used
to call friends. It's none of that, right? It is none of that.
It's just that they want to pay money
to hurt him.
That's very That's very interesting.
She said she wants that. No, she said she wants him to be punished
for this, but I don't think she wants to be p him to be punished
for this at a massive expense to her with no restitution whatsoever.
And the only way she's getting restitution is by going to trial.
Yeah. So, but I am I am excited that Destiny has this uh this
mindset because if if they make it through a motion to dismiss
and a motion for summary judgement, then
I I don't know how he settles at this point, right? He's been
totally wronged. I don't know how he could possibly settle. And
as he pushes himself further in the corner where he can't settle
anymore, um that just I mean that's a W for anybody who thinks
he's a terrible human being who doesn't deserve his platform
or his money. FYI, the plagiarism case they site, it looks like
the expert not only ripped entire paragraphs from another source
without citing, but he also selectively edited the paragraphs
to misleadingly shape the narrative of the work he was plagiarizing.
Yeah. So, it's not even remotely close. And I suspected this
vigilant stream because normally when they cite a case, they
go into a lot of detail about why that case ex like supports
them, right? And I feel like they did not go so plagiarism. I
feel like they're normally far more precise in this. I from what
I've seen like when they when they think they have a source that
helps they're far more precise. Who's coping hard today? Yeah,
we got a couple clips. We'll check out some of the clips.
Uh what do we got? How how much time do we have left on the stream
here, guys? We got 58 minutes left. We are
looks like 10 subs. 10 subs for two more hours in the stream,
guys. If you if you like the content, you want more content.
Okay, go ahead. Donate. Add more time to the stream. Appreciate
all the viewers here. All right, we're going to make it through
this no matter what. But I appreciate all the viewers. I also
appreciate all of your support. If you like the content, you
want more content tonight. Go ahead, sub, donate, give a couple
bucks, throw in a couple kicks.
Love you guys. I'm not going to chill for too long. I just want
to keep going with uh
I want to keep going with these
>> A Okay.
All right. I don't know if that delusional, but >> the
next clip. >> Yeah, I think it would be really rough for
them.
>> How? Oh, Marty Epstein, thank for the five, buddy. Let's
go. Let's go. I I don't know how
why would it be rough for them.
I would just love for him to say why why would a trial be rough
for them if Okay, hypothetically, let's say hypothetically,
um Pixie literally can't improve her reputation. She doesn't
have the platform to fight against you at all. So, Desty just
gets to run rough shot over Pixie with any narrative he wants,
right? But a trial, it's like actually putting it in front of
some impartial people who aren't terminally
I How could it not improve from there? It can only improve, right?
Yeah. He thinks this, frugals, but unfortunately,
no matter what he says about her
if people go home and Google this guy, they're going to be disgusted,
right? Like it could only hurt him. So this is like more fronting
that is just very funny to me. There's just I don't know why
he has to make up such insane that he's like, "Oh, yeah. We should
totally It'd be really bad for her to go to trial." >> But
written discovery is ongoing and depositions have not yet been
conducted. Written discovery.
>> Doesn't he always say she has nothing to lose? Yeah.
Like realistically, I don't understand how he could say that
she could lose something at trial. She's apparently losing all
of her money, spending all of her money just to hurt him now.
Going to trial hurts him way
>> Only began after the court granted Plaintiff's protective
order on September 2nd, 2025. plan to produce over 3,000 documents
on September 5th with additional productions on September 22nd.
Um, so they add this in here to He gets really mad. He's going
to get totally
booty bothered, anally annihilated over the fact that it's 3,000
documents, but it's like 3,000 messages where the messages have
individual timestamps on them, like individual XML or HTML files.
He gets he gets so
booty bothered about this kind of stuff. Okay, sound like fancy
or whatever. So, of the 3,000 documents that they produced, about
2,800 of them are just single lines of text. So, for instance,
there's like a group chat, I think, that a bunch of people were
in. And that group chat is 1,000 documents because every single
individual message is thrown into its own text file. I don't
know if this is standard practice, if like courts are literally
just kangaroo courts or >> Well, I think hold on. Destiny
Destiny's done this already. Destiny's literally practiced synchronizing
things with timestamps, right? He knows how to merge files. Does
he understand abstraction at all? Destiny, you wrote something
that will put documents in a certain order that they'll put it
like uh JSON, HTML, whatever the in a certain order and you can
combine multiple files. If you generalize this system, you could
easily make it so it could take up to n documents, whatever n
is, and it could just merge them all into one file over time.
This is very possible. You've learned all of the elements. It's
very weird when I I always find it weird when I meet somebody.
This is like the number one thing I'd look for for denying candidates
for a job, right? As programmers, when you can't identify abstractions
that generalize to other things
like this is not even remotely a difficult thing for I assume
a law firm would have some IT department that just coaleses this
into something immediately, right?
Like it's actually not a problem for anyone with any level of
intellect.
Yeah. I don't know. This is very sad when you see this. I can
do that with Chat GPT. I'm confident. Yeah. Well, he did it with
Chat GPT or he tried to, right? This is very easy. I don't know
why he uh I don't know why he's acting like he's so different
or just a joke in the United States or if this is just a thing
that was designed to waste my time or to waste everything. So,
I have to >> Oh, this is uh this is going to be a funny
one. Okay.
>> Terials would indicate that the defendant's ESI was
not collected and preserved in a forensically sound manner. I'm
about to tri the out of me with all this. This is just so all
of this is so stupid. Okay, this failure constitutes a critical
deficiency as the foundational principle of digital forensics
dictates that cryptographic hash values must be generated at
the time of collection to ensure the integrity and authenticity
of the data.
Without these,
this is a way you can do this. Absolutely. All they would need
is the hash value on Pixie side, right? They would need the the
hash value. so that they could compare it after the >> You
need digital identifiers. There is no reliable method to determine
if the data set has been altered or compromised at any point
after its initial collection.
Okay. I don't know if this guy just watched his first hackers
movie or what, but oh, this is how you know about the DG brain
drain, right? Does he not have anybody who could explain how
this stuff works for him? I I feel like he's about to say some
really insane [__] You could easily do this in a
way where you could provide proof. Okay, you provide proof very
easily
that you've archived this stuff. You go here's the hashes for
the stuff I've archived. This is the the for my overall trove
of like archive,
>> right? You could you could upload that to a eiscocovery
platform that saves all that stuff. You could easily do this.
It's like one Google search away. You'd have no problems. It
would just be some cloud stuff that would be immutable. You'd
upload to it and you would have you'd probably just upload the
initial stuff you you went through right
>> now. You could Did he lose employees? He did. But um
but
uh probably what he should argue is that if he were to immediately
like archive everything, if you were to to pull it all down,
>> modify it, then archive it in a way that like generates
the hashes, like he could still do the edits and then that could
never be tracked, right? He would create his own record that
has like proofs there. So there's always a hole because I think
what a lot of the eiscocovery platforms should be doing as far
as I know is you should be giving them like an API API key for
Discord and you could just dump all of your Discord into it via
API like it could go grab that itself and keep a record then
I mean even then he could still edit but then it then it's very
easy to get caught right editing things because if he's like
deleting lines and they ever do get a subpoena through Discord
for the same and they can compare he's like totally hooped and
he will be like triple hooped. for that. So would be would be
what a cryptographic hash is is that you are essentially um you're
essentially sending you're like you take imagine you take a bunch
of data um like on a paint picture or on a PDF or whatever and
then you run through all of this data and um I'm sure there there
are probably more sophisticated ways to do this but like b like
imagine you take every single um piece of data and and you find
a way to just like mathematically convert it into some string
of um 32 64 128 256 characters or whatever and um it's you can't
like
the number of characters makes like absolutely no difference
here at all. Uh he's just saying it as if it like he he googled
this, he looked at it on Wikipedia. He's going to say that oh
like this is some this is Wikipedia knowledge, right? Like it's
it's so it's so like irrelevant to this that it's just funny
to hear this like he's focusing on this as if it's a relevant
detail, right? And if you've actually worked this stuff up, you're
just like, "Oh, why are you You're like weirdly, you're doing
the you know." Um Oh, it's this. It's this. Okay. It's just this
thing. Okay.
>> The scene starts with >> No, no, no, no, no, no,
no. Stop. Stop. Stop. Stop. Stop. Oh, dude. I'm not finding anything.
Okay. It's just this scene again. Okay. That's all it is. It's
like that scene. You can just see that somebody like isn't really
>> We order glasses. Somebody's not really
Somebody somebody doesn't really know what they're talking about.
Destiny probably thinks it's based 64. >> Wake at night
and open, you know, 500 text files at a time and go through every
single one so that I can see if there's anything relevant. >> I'm
definitely on the wrong clip. Whoops. Doesn't allow you to get
back to the original data. But what it does is it's like a mathematical
um symbol.
>> It's a fingerprint for that set of data. It's a fingerprint
for that set of data that cannot be easily recreated of a unique
value generated by all the underlying data. What that means is
that if I alter the data in some way and then I hash it using
the exact same algorithm as was hashed before, if I change any
of the underlying data, then the hash that's generated is going
to be different than the prior one. So a hash doesn't allow me
to go back to the original data like some form of like encryption
or conversion or whatever. But what it does allow me to do is
to check if the original data has been modified in some way.
Okay,
now take a step back here. Okay. Um, yeah, I'm sorry. It's not
a unique hash. It could like theoretically two different hashes.
Could I feel like there was a really really really It's unique
enough. Okay. It's unique enough. What's uh
Oh, man.
Is it Uyu ID 3? There's one of the UR one of the UU ID RFC's
is like the number of like unique strings is more more than the
number of like atoms in the known universe or something like
there's just nothing. It's just never going to you're fine. You're
never >> Unique database leak. >> That's different
than hashing. But it's >> they used a hashing algorithm
that was stupid because you could theoretically have two different
passwords generate the same hash because it was a really small
it was a really short I don't remember. This was a long time
ago. This is irrelevant though. This is like niche stupid [__]
The big issue, okay, the stupid part here with talking about
anything having to do with a cryptographic hash value is a concept,
okay, called chain of custody. All right, you are asking me
for a cryptographic hash. Why?
All I have to do if I'm going to doctor evidence is doctor the
evidence and then hash it. Why the would me giving you
>> this is why I think the primary argument was that you
didn't hire you didn't use an eiscocovery platform and you didn't
hire anybody to do this for you right I think that's like the
problem here and realistically because there isn't an effective
chain of custody that could be managed here like realistically
you should have to go and subpoena Discord and get like the the
independent logs produced by Discord right to look for deletions
around that time like this would have been if you had trust me
if they if there trying to find, you know, Charlie Kirk's killer.
If if the FBI was on it, they would have gone and gotten that
data from Discord right away. And then that would have all been
handled like a correct way, right? To actually preserve evidence.
>> Yeah, you could say don't delete the original Discord
logs. See, to me, if you want to delete the original Discord
logs to protect your privacy, I think you have to go engage with
some eiscocovery platform. You have to figure out the way to
do that without without like actually hurting Chain of Custody
in my opinion. Yeah, I feel like I feel like that should be a
direction they they should have taken the case and they are kind
of taking it there now, but like they should have taken the case
in that direction because why the hasn't this been decided at
like a federal level somewhere? Has it really not been like is
this just a thing where it's like, oh, I can actually delete
all of that evidence from the platforms it was on, right?
Including relevant messages.
I can delete all of it as long as I create an archive that that
breaks chain of custody.
It just it feels strange to I feel like that can't possibly be
the case. But >> a cryptographic hash verify the authenticity
of anything I'm showing you. The chain of custody starts with
me. This is such a stupid argument. It makes no sense. The chain
of custody should start with the platform the messages are stored
on. There's a platform that's holding that data that can basically
say like with an actual audit log, what's been deleted? What's
there? You you don't even retain that unless you have some special
program going on, right? Like Discord doesn't retain the messages
for you with deleted timestamps. I don't think there's any export
that does that. Is there? Is there an export that shows deleted
timestamps? Maybe there is. I'm trying to think of what the API
returns if it returns like um deleted messages with like a deleted
flag on them. I don't think it does.
The equivalent here to a cryptographic hash is taking a photograph
of like a crime scene before investigators start messing with.
Okay. Why you take the photographs first so that you can see
how everything originally was. This is an important part of a
crime scene. Now, imagine how stupid it would be to have photographs
of a crime scene if the first photographs you have are photographs
made by the accused.
Do you know how stupid this would be? Wait, is he like he is
actually just functionally arguing?
He's arguing that he should have to give up all of the logs they're
requesting from Discord. That like he should actually go to Discord
and say reproduce those,
right?
like like he is he is explaining why everybody is like so annoyed
about this that like yeah you're literally the person who's accused
of the murder and you've taken the pictures and gone you you
basically got to the scene first okay we're going to accuse you
of the murder you took a picture of the scene and then a bunch
of it's sorry you took
you were there the scene was a certain way it's been modified
you modified it to protect your privacy and then you took a picture
you're like hey the picture's from before trust me like we have
to just trust you that you even touched anything. I saw the streamable.
You linked Maximus. Oh, you're asking >> J. Oh, no. No.
We have We have photos of the original crime scene. Oh, who gave
you the photographs? The guy being accused of murder.
Oh, well, what if he like just moved the bodies first?
H Well, yeah. This is why you probably should have This is actually
He's literally explaining why he should be guilty of expoliation.
He's He's explaining why he should be guilty of expoliation,
right? Like he deleted them from the third party platform. He
deleted all of these logs after he was given notice,
right? After he was definitely aware that he was going to be
sued, he deleted all these messages.
I don't This is like This is crazy right now. That's a you know,
that's a good point. This whole cryptographic hash argument is
so stupid because if I was gonna
um people said that his argument around hashes I think he um
he doesn't really know but he is correct in the argument he uses
for why like hashes might not help with him but his his argument
that he's not spioliating that he there is no spillation of evidence
is I can delete these messages that are relevant right from the
third party platform that would maintain an independent record
of them because I'm recreating that record and then he did not
recreate that independent record. Right?
So, I believe he shouldn't have had to delete these things. And
I think Pixie actually would be guilty of exploation as well
under this. She deleted a message. That message should be used
against her, right? Whatever that message was. But I think he
had screenshots of that message anyway. So, I think you already
know what it is. But like she's guilty in this in a similar way,
just a way lower magnitude. Um, no, he didn't delete in December
though. Junararch. There's actually there's some documented evidence
of this of people realizing he was deleting stuff in January
at some point. Like it was um in January or even February. It
was like after the original lawsuit was filed as far as I know
that like his messages started getting deleted with everybody.
So he's arguing that his record so he went to the crime scene.
The only objective like evidence of this happening, he deleted
a bunch of stuff. He moved it all around and he went, "I took
pictures so it's okay that I move stuff around." That's his argument.
And now he's going, "You don't you shouldn't have access to my
pictures. Why don't you go to the why don't you go to the crime
scene?" It's like, "Uh, what? That's that's bizarre. That's a
really weird argument." And he's going, "Well, you haven't proven
I did the murder. Show me proof that show me a video of me murdering
that person." Like, what?
Doctor anything? I could just doctor a thing and then give them
a hash and it wouldn't prove anything. It's so stupid.
this principle is the cornerstone of digital forensics practice.
Okay, for comparison reference, the plaintiff's acquisition log
of her mobile phone, which includes the requisite cryptographic
hash values, is attached here too as exhibit B. Now, the thing
that triggers me so much about that's uh that's Rose's um DMV
records. That's proof that you minor. Wrong wrong document. That's
proof you minor. >> the um Oh, wait. This is exhibit B
and his own thing. Sorry. The thing that triggers me so much
about this stupid argument and then his stay here. Okay. He's
saying that because the defendant
provided a cryptographic hash
of her cell phone that some that she created an archive of all
of the data that she wants to reference all the potential data
and she could show like as a chain that she's used that to extract
into something and then I assume from there she could comb through
and get data from inside of that as well that she'd have hashes
on the files inside of there that she she could show that that
that manifest,
right? So, she'd have a manifest of files with hashes attached
and then you'd have the hash of the collection, the bundle, and
that manifest would have all the file. You'd extract, you'd look
at all the files inside, they would all hash correctly to the
same values, right? Like I it's easy to conceive of. By the way,
I'm making this up entirely. I assume this is how it would go
because this is naturally how you would work it. You can make
this. This is, by the way, all of this stuff is precisely
why like uh what do you call it? Um you you can you can make
these systems very reliably. Okay, this is essentially to in
a in a slightly different way how cryptocurrency works, right?
Is like you can confirm things happen at certain times. You can
with like evidence in a decentralized way that you don't need
a centralized authorities like understanding of or or um control
over
and you can create things that are like reliably following some
process. So I he's going to go after this. I'm guessing this
is some like actual legal thing to show that you have not possibly
destroyed any evidence and that if this is the standard to show
you're not expoliating to show there's a lack of expoliation
then he absolutely didn't follow that. Somehow this means that
the information that she's given me is right and true. But there's
a few there's several problems with this. Okay. Number one, if
she's deleted anything on her phone before making that
I have no record of that. I don't know if this hat is telling
me what was on the phone >> prior to um you know her taking
that. Obviously, it only tells me the time she made the hat.
Number one. >> Number two,
all of the information that we are fighting about right now,
all of the information we're fighting about right now has to
do with messages on Discord. Discord messages are stored. He
just spent the first whole 10 pages of this stupid expert witness
summary on Discord servers, not on her.
Okay. I
I What? How is he sounding so condescending when he's I don't
understand how people don't put this together? Oh, it's all a
Discord. So, why isn't she going to Discord to get this? Well,
I think she is. I think you're like rejecting a lot of her. As
far as I understood, you were rejecting her ability to do that,
right? Yeah. Well, Haddie, I think he understands that like hashing
this information creates a record that can no longer be tampered
with, right? and that like yeah, you could delete some major
piece of evidence, but especially when hashing a phone, you would
get like other audit log data, right? Um, one big piece here
that people don't think about is when you go to something like
Discord, every single service provider, every single uh what
would you call it? Like tech company will retain audit logs as
in logs explaining like metadata changes, uh, files being deleted,
things being added,
right, changes over time. They'll have audit logs of stuff way
longer than they'll retain actual rich files. And so what they
could do is if you created some sort of audit log like this,
it could go, "Okay, as of this date, this is what you're submitting.
Now we can look at the audit logs and see if you've changed anything
since then. We could look at the audit log, see if you changed
anything right before that,
Um,
yeah, he's being condescending in a way that like also makes
it clear. He's basically yelling at the top of his lungs, I should
never have deleted anything from Discord. I shouldn't have done
that. It was relevant to the case and I actually destroyed the
record of it that could be reliably or so that could be relied
upon because I'm the murderer. Her phone,
sorry, accused murderer. This doesn't tell me anything about
what's on her Discord account. This is basically just a snapshot
of of a it's like a disk image of her phone's drive and it's
a hash value of what's on the phone's drive. This doesn't tell
me anything about what's what we're contesting over over what's
on any social media account cuz that information is stored on
her phone. Like it also won't tell me because this cryptographic
hash this cryptographic hash is also is also worthless. Actually,
it's even worthless for another reason that I didn't even consider
before because this hash I think was made I feel like I remember
seeing this hash was made on in March of this year.
Yeah, this hash is made on >> Isn't it the same reason
he gave before that you could modify data >> here? She
could be sending and deleting messages after this hash every
This only would allow me to analyze the contents of her phone's
drive as of March um as >> Isn't that the same argument
he just made that like, oh, she could have modified it before?
I thought that was the little argument he made to begin >> March
28th, 2025. Anything afterwards? I don't have any cryptographic
hashes showing like text messages or anything. Right. And also,
I don't know if she's deleted or anything before taking this
screenshot here. So, like just all of this is stupid, right?
This is just such a pointless. It's such a pointless stupid argument.
It's saying that she's making a record of this with a hash, a
time stamp that says at this point, this is what data was on
her phone. It's like better than nothing. And it can be like
relied upon, right? Could be relied upon to show changes over
time. Yeah, it's that's what it's doing. That is the purpose
of it. And yes, you could have just deleted something immediately
from Discord and then just continued on and and archived everything.
Yes, you could have. I I don't know what he's saying. This is
better than what exists now where it could be edited at any point
going forward, right?
The whole point is like to do the best you can. I guess the idea
that you would talk about a cryptographic hash when the chain
of custody
starts with
when the chain of custody starts with
now he's he's changed this argument. the chain of custody either
starts with him or Discord, but I'm not totally sure. Apparently,
he's changed his mind on that because if the chain of custody
starts with Discord and he deleted all of his messages from Discord,
he has expoliated he's destroyed evidence. He is guilty of expoliation,
right? But if the chain of custody starts with him, well, I don't
know if the if the chain of custody starts with him, then why
is he saying that Discord's relevant and it's about Discord servers
earlier on in the clip? I don't know. I don't even know what
this is. >> The person being accused of the of the malfeence.
It doesn't make any sense why you would care about my hash.
But somebody said, "Destiny, if you open Discord on the phone,
the data is on the phone." Uh, yes or no. One, Discord will store
some data locally on your phone, but not all of it. And two,
it's only going to store data of recently opened messages, and
I don't even know if that data is wiped when the phone is restarted
or not. You can test this yourself. Go onto your phone and open
Discord, and then open a message that you have open like already.
>> Is this Abby screenshot, right? what >> and the
immediate text might be there. Okay, it might be there, it might
not. And then just scroll up a little bit and you're going to
see a little loading symbol. That loading symbol if you try to
let's say you open Discord, like you can do this. You can open
Discord. You can
By the way, this is him having like a week, two weeks to think
about it. I' I've rolled into this. I like literally have no
I didn't look at any of this stuff before today. Riyle sent me
these clips. I had no idea what was going on on this stream.
So, if I if I can poke holes in the things he's saying,
I feel like other people have to be able to other people have
to say or see that he's like,
I'm not going to say the walls are closing in, but these aren't
good
I don't know. Anyway, open a text message or not a text message,
a Discord message. You can turn on airplane mode on your phone.
Now, try to scroll up. You can't access it because Discord doesn't
have that data. All of your conversations are saved locally to
your phone. They're pulling them from um Discord CDN.
They're not pulling it from Discord CDN. Why would messages be
scored
on a CDN?
See, he This is just one of those things that it's funny. He
tries to use technical terms without knowing what they mean and
then he'll like accuse other people of not knowing what they
are. Is very funny, right? Um they're actually those messages
are pulled from the Discord CDN.
Why would you store text messages in a CDN? That makes no
Okay. This is just This is so stupid.
Oh my god. At Destiny, chain of custody hashes are usually collected
before any examination of the disc. Yeah, sure. But they're also
usually collected by like Oh, so somebody's just like explaining
that he's obviously Yeah.
Hey, yeah, we're going to do like a hash on It's like I assume
you would build like an archive, right? An archive.
Um you you get everything. you build like a manifest of the files
you're saving and then with it with that manifest you then archive
and um and build one more hash to show that that's when it all
happened right so you'd want to have the manifest showing all
the hashes of the files inside and then you'd want to do another
hash I think of the archive itself and that would be like okay
this is how I'm showing that I've like not that everything inside
here it's all going to be the same when you pull it out you could
verify all of this on your own
hashes on hashes but why because the external hash shows that
the archive hasn't been tampered with, that you haven't rearchived
things. And the manifest of hashes within the archive is so that
you can guar so that you can do the same for the files inside.
Um because otherwise you just have an archive. You could make
sure it's not like tampered with.
But then what would happen then? Um oh maybe you only need the
archive. Why did I think you need the manifest uh like a manifest
with hashes of stuff inside? No, you might not need that. You
might not need that at all.
That might be right. Investigator
like by people who are seizing your like if the FBI were to come
and steal all your they would probably make a hash at the beginning
just to verify um you know as they investigate as they do stuff
that like nothing's being changed or whatever. Uh in this case
it's it's Discord logs, right? So, I think probably the issue
is I think really what should have happened and it's sad that
it didn't was Andrew um Andrew Breler the lawyer should have
had somebody on on staff who could collect this evidence for
Destiny to maintain a chain of custody that you at least have
some authority there that you can respect in some way, right?
Um it could I'm trying to think I'd have to walk through this
again. Um, I just feel I feel like there's some reason maybe
so that you could like uh pull those files out and show the the
hashes that match with the manifest. I don't >> But like
you would never file just Oh, right, right, right. You'd make
the archive and then you'd have the individual hashes. So you
could show the archive was made on a certain time or at a certain
time and you'd have the manifest that would show that each of
the things and then they'd have to subpoena like either each
of the individual things or whatever, right? Maybe in some use
cases you would. I don't know. But I can't imagine you ever ask
an accused, hey, can you give us a hash of the data before you
send it to us so we can make sure you haven't docked or anything?
It's like, oh, okay,
let me go ahead and uh doctor my first and then I'll make the
h just stupid. It's so um wouldn't you more easily be able to
create an arbitrary file to get the correct hash? You can't do
this with sufficiently like complex algorithm. You can't do this.
You can't create like an arbitrary file to get the correct hash.
Um no,
no, this isn't a risk. But uh yeah, it's not. >> Oh, stupid.
But okay, the defendant's mismanagement renders the production
entirely unreliable as it cannot be authenticated if asked to
reproduce findings from it. Simply put, there is no way to run
a cryptographic algorithm that will ensure the data was not altered
after being preserved because there is no value to compare it
to. Thus, defendants evidence is not reliable and cannot be authenticated.
Let's say that we roll with all of this despite how stupid this
argument is for at least seven different reasons. Okay, let's
say that we roll with all of this. Okay, fine. You got me. I
didn't make the random arbitrary cryptographic hash. What do
you have for
Because all you have
So again, his argument was he was Yeah. His his argument is literally
I had to delete these messages to to protect my privacy, right?
But it's not spoliation, right? I haven't deleted evidence because
because
I backed everything up. Now, he can't prove that he backed everything
up. He can't do any of that because he didn't go through a third
party. He did it all himself, right? So, it is like the murderer
basically taking changing around the crime scene,
taking a picture and going, "Look, I took a picture or sorry,
a murderer taking a picture of the crime scene, right? And saying,
I look, I didn't switch anything around." And it's like, but
but how can I believe that? Like, you're you're not a person
who could do this. We need a third party who can do this. Now,
would cryptographic hashes from him help? No, that's probably
not something you would say, right?
Unless you Sorry. Cryptographic hashes could help to determine
like changes after like at a later date, but they're not super
helpful. They're just one of the signs that you would have hired
like an expert to help you do this. I think in general, the cryptographic
hash stuff is mostly just saying you didn't hire an expert to
do this.
>> Are screenshots that were posted on Kiwi
from like an obviously malicious user. You don't have any >> from
an obviously Okay. Did that user lie? Where is the Where's
Excuse me. That's a genetic fallacy. You're saying that something's
wrong because it was produced from a source that you don't like.
That's not real. And uh can you just can you reckon with the
actual evidence, please? Thank you. >> Cryptographic hash
it. Like I could theoretically just say if we're going to roll
with that, I can say actually I don't think I ever sent any I
don't think I ever contacted that account at Your honor, your
honor. Your honor, this evidence, this this fact of reality that
nobody challenges, not even me, was produced by somebody named
Coke. Therefore, it's inadmissible. Excuse your honor. Your honor,
all of those messages from that account were actually just memes.
And I actually think Pix
Oh, the funny thing is I actually do wonder here. Do you think
that he knows or Andrew knows? This is actually the more obvious,
right? This is the more obvious explanation is Andrew knows,
Destiny knows that the Kiwi Farm stuff is total that like there's
no real argument or way to discredit an expert witness using
that argument. Um because he he just cited something that is
a fact, right? They know that, but they're just putting it in
the uh the filings so that it is covered by people and they can
run with the like, oh, Kiwi Farms is ruining this guy's life
narrative, right? Pixie is only using Kiwi Farms for stuff.
I, by the way, I don't know why you wouldn't use Kiwi. If you
were in a lawsuit with somebody and they had a Kiwi Farms thread,
why would you not use you? They literally have like like awesome
They have skits who do all the work for you. Literally, they
just do all of the work for you. They literally go they're like
obsessively following this stuff. They have like expertise in
exactly what this person said before. They are going to make
your best arguments. They are studying this person like a lab
rat, right? I'm sorry.
They're Yes, exactly. CD. They're literally obsessed evidence
gatherers.
That's That's what they are. Now, if this guy had gone and he
had done some malicious narrative, right? Oh, this guy this guy
was in the stream before the stream started. I can't wait to
hear JTO's arguments in favor of this Jesus guy. Okay. I don't
I don't think I've made any bad arguments, but maybe people will
contend with them. Um
Oh, where was I going?
Oh, yeah. Yeah. Yeah. If he' taken like whole paragraphs of like
fanfiction written on uh Kiwi Farms, then that would be bad,
right? If he was plagiarizing some whole line of theory that
could be easily disproven that was just some, you know, Kiwi
Farms person writing like an unhinged post about Destiny, okay?
Unhinged and and
If if that's what was happening, then you would just show how
it was wrong and how that was like really like it it clearly
demonstrated that they're not a professional. But it's like they
didn't contend with like they didn't say, "Oh, he's wrong on
anything." as far as I can tell. I I don't know. I dude, I'm
sitting here and it's just like I don't I don't understand.
I don't understand how this could possibly be like a relevant
thing. And he's like, "Oh, clearly malicious user posted it."
>> All of those messages from that account were actually
just memes. And I actually think Pixie leaked their own [__]
on the internet just to try to with me. I don't think any of
that was from me. Like what a stupid argument.
>> Wait, what? Malicious user. >> What did he just
say? >> You don't have any cryptographic hashes. Like I
could theoretically just say if we're going to roll with that,
I could say actually I don't think I ever sent any me. I don't
think I ever contacted that account at all. All of those messages
from that account were actually just memes and I actually think
Pixie leaked their own [__] on the internet just
to try to [__] with me. I don't think any of that
was from me. Like what a stupid argument.
He's just continuously repeatedly making like a bunch of points
to the court that say Discord are the only people with the true
record of this and Pixie needs to go get stuff from Discord and
I shouldn't even be like I shouldn't even be trying to stop her
from doing that. That's like what he's saying here objectively.
It's very funny but okay
There is significant evidence of apparent document tampering
related to defendants document production.
uh, let's see here. Export. I I don't know. So, I don't know
about um this section. I think this is the section that they
amended.
I do believe Destiny, despite knowing that it will be amended,
right? I do believe he'll go read it because he really wants
to focus in on the thing they amended before there was a response.
Uh,
wait, KF is considered a true record, huh? I mean KF is considered
that like if they have something that is so what what that KF
post was doing it was taking evidence Destiny himself submitted
and pointing out weird holes in that evidence right and the guy
said oh there are weird holes in that evidence oh this is something
okay yeah I'm going to point this out right it's like it's taking
base level facts it' be like taking a clip of Destiny and looking
at his words and then going oh Destiny said this that's that's
all that's happening here right
Um, and he's pretending that that clip being posted on Kiwi Farms
somehow poisons that clip as evidence of something.
And that's just not true. The fact that Code Cave posted excerpts
from Destiny's actual submitted evidence on Kiwi Farms
does not mean that that evidence is no longer valid or relevant
or
You can't just, if that were the case, you could just post a
bunch of that proves you're guilty on Kiwi Farms and then go,
"Well,
Kiwi Farm, it's on Kiwi Farms. use it. Look posted that can't
use it and to his evidence submitted in support of his motion
to dismiss. Now again, keep in mind they are nitpicking all of
my evidence so hard to try to show that I've like, you know,
tampered with something, maliciously altered something. Now,
keep in mind through all of this, there are two things to keep
in mind. One, I already know that the plaintiff maliciously altered
her messages. She's never ever ever responded to this in an email.
She's never responded to this in a court filing. I know that
she malicious altered because I have two pieces, strong pieces
of evidence. One is she deleted the part where she said that
she was going to ask me for more money, but she'd feel bad about
me saying no. She >> Yeah, this is uh this is her version
of expoliation. I think that she should be found guilty of expoliation
for that and that should be used against her by
uh whatever what do you call it? Jury. Yeah, absolutely. She
could she should get fined for that. That's totally fine. That's
absolutely expoliation. And Dest has every right to be bad about
that in the same way that he expoliated, you know, all of the
all of his side of the >> She deleted that message. She's
never
The only reason I know that I have a screenshot of that part
of our conversation and number two in my own archives of our
logs that she went back and she edited at least one message that
was sent months ago on January 20th the day before she sent me
the request for evidence preservation. So that's two examples
of what is >> that's actually really bad. She shouldn't
have done that. You should file a motion on that. >> Obvious
spoilation, obvious malicious spoilation. She's deleting or altering
things that she knows will help her court case. Otherwise, why
else would she go back 3 months and edit a message a day before
sending me a request for preservation, right? So, I already know
that she's engaged in this exact behavior in a malicious manner.
Um, they're trying to accuse me of doing it, but they're doing
it against nothing. They have no evidence. Nothing that they
have requested from me have I not been able to produce perfectly
and flawlessly. And nothing that I produced has ever been in
um contradiction with anything else. It's not like I've shown
something and they've been like, "Oh, look, we proved that defendant
lighter." No, that's
so Wait, why why is it now not a big deal? Okay, I produce it
cleanly and flawlessly from his previous argument. Says the murderer,
says the accused murderer of the crime scene photo. I reproduce
this flawlessly, guys. Hey, why
why did you go to the crime scene and change things around?
Basically, how would this go? This is like finding out somebody
was is going to be accused of murder. Somebody finds out, right?
They get videotaped at a place
um where a murders happened. Okay, they get videotaped there.
They run away. They come back before the cops get there and they
take pictures of the crime scene and they go and the cops go,
"Wait, why did you go back there after you like you knew you
were being accused? This person said, "Oh, murderer. You know
you're going to be accused." And he's like, "Well, I I just want
to go take pictures to make sure like I preserve the crime scene
for myself." And then um you could use that. You totally use
It's like, "Do you believe that he didn't touch anything? Do
you believe that he didn't edit do anything there?" I don't know.
Seems kind of
No, man.
Never happened. All of my logs are good. All of my records are
preserved perfectly. And I've kept every single thing that I've
needed to for this case. And I produce every single thing I need
to for this case. The only thing they can do is these weird um
technologically
uh technologically
attacks on how I'm storing stuff. And it's just so stupid. But
okay, there is significant evidence of apparent document tampering
related to defense. Oh, right. This is going to be uh he could
he can go through this if he wants. I think they retracted this
whole thing. They just said like, "Oh, there's a they like they
missed something messed something up in here." I pointed this
out that like, "Oh, I just went and looked at like the Discord
group messaging timing and it was like, oh, that's obviously
what's happening here. I don't think this is evidence of what
they say it was." And then they amended the complaint. Let's
go. So, I don't know why you'd take this as the existing record,
but okay.
I need to go to the next clip. We're almost done with this stuff.
Oh, I'm already on this. Okay. So
this is particularly funny, but also particularly I guess
identifiers in the URLs from the chat history do not match the
same from the list the defendant prepared of media files sent
to Discord screen named ABMC. See below.
So
this is particularly funny but also particularly I guess since
my life is a joke. I'm really only laughing at this stuff. Okay,
I want you to understand, okay? All of this is just kind of funny
to me because I'm rich. Okay, if I if this was like 3 years earlier
in my career, I actually don't know what I would do for stuff
like this. Um because I well I would have got a significantly
cheaper law firm and then I guess we would go to court fighting
over this because I don't like it's just an unbelievable set
of circumstances. So let me explain. Okay, remember this is an
expert unbelievable unhinged crazy set of circumstances, guys.
You have no idea. I'd be so cooked before this, but now that
I'm me and now that I'm like him, uh I've I've totally got this
in the in the bag. in the bag. He's already shown a a surprising
level of tech incompetency leading up to this. Not thinking like
imagine the claims he's made in this so far that Discord's entire
CDN is exposed to the open internet for archiving. So every single
DM media file has been exposed to search engines for indexing,
right? Prior to
>> uh that is just true. It was exposed but it wasn't crawable.
>> I I explained and even still today it's just 24 links,
right? It's already surprisingly stupid. What a what a stupid
statement to put in an expert. >> We'll see. I'm going
to find it very funny cuz I think I had the best argument for
why this wasn't a good argument. We'll just see if um we'll see
how Desi's chat handles it. If he's going to just ape my arguments
one to one for why this is like not actually a thing that should
really count in their >> Testimony. Um he's shown incompetence
over how Discord displays its messages. Um okay. But now, >> oh
wait, no, this is the OCR stuff. I'll have to go back to a different
>> He's going to say that with these links being different
demon.
>> Oh, timer. Yeah, hold on. I should show one more time,
guys. Let me see here. We've got 14 minutes left on the stream.
We are We are five subs away from another two hours on the stream.
Let's go. Let's get those five subs in. We've got What do we
have left on the night here? We've got a couple different pieces
of content. We've got all of the politics stuff. Okay. All the
politics stuff and possibly either Fuentes on Red Scare. Yeah,
possibly Fentes on Red Scare. We could take a look at that. Yeah,
I'm interested in both of those. >> straight. Okay. They
demonstrate that I have tampered with the evidence. Now, I
>> Let's call the bluff. Uh I I wouldn't call the bluff
today.
>> Private Huff with the five gifted. Oh, nobody's got
to call the bluff. Okay,
>> Listen, I'd finish this no matter what,
>> don't know why my law firm did this. Okay. I don't know
what's going on or what or how they handle their documents, but
the thing is is that if you look at the evidence tampering, it's
pretty obvious that what's happened is it looks like they used
a scanner or something. They printed something off and then scanned
it. And when the scanner was translating the information from
visual back to text, the scanner missed a few things. So, for
instance, I have a link here and it says WBT
slash view, but the T slash it read as a um it read as
I did like what did they say here? Cuz I don't know what is he
going to argue. Wasn't this um this is signs of evidence tampering?
He's saying that the evidence has been changed and there's no
record to even show these changes. So, we're just lucky we caught
it, which is all true.
Um it's not maliciously done. I like I said it's almost certainly
done through incompetence.
Maybe is Dest's argument that like no I this was this was modified
through incompetence and not through intent obviously
maybe that okay >> there's a V here right that T slash
instead of reading it as T slash that whatever transcribed it
read it as a V and then same thing down here you have a um I
don't even know if there's anything wrong here maybe it missed
an underscore I guess right here and just put a space right so
again if you are an expert witness this is something that you
should know. Okay, you should know this. Like, oh, this is a
common transcription error from, you know, something reading
text.
Do you think like here's the real question, okay? Cuz it's like,
does he not understand the argument the guy's making or
like is he dumb or intentionally ignorant, right? Willfully ignorant.
It's hard to say, okay? Because what the guy is trying to build
towards is, hey, you have like no record of modifications happening
to these messages. We have no way to confirm that these messages
are unmodified. We have no way to confirm that like any of this
stuff isn't being with and that's the concerning part. And so
any modification that you haven't explicitly outlined, we're
going to say that that's evidence tampering because you are [__]
up, right?
That's that's the whole point of this is they're saying you we
have evidence that you are with this evidence, right? And I don't
think so
it depends I guess on oh more evidence of tampering tampering
has occurred right there is there is a discrepancy here that
shouldn't be there now we could easily predict why that discrepancy
would be here
but is that relevant
is it relevant to their expert testimony to go well I suspect
that he is just an incompetent loser who used OCR instead of
typing things out or instead of like and instead of like comparing
these two strings he just submitted like, "Yeah, okay." Or his
lawyers are incompetent losers. Either one, do they have to speculate
on that? Or could they just say, "Well, it's clearly clearly
these things are different." I feel like it's obviously the second
one. I don't know where where are Destiny's lawyers, where has
Andrew Breler steelman Pixie side of the lawsuit?
>> Can somebody explain that to me? Why? How in the world
are all of these people actually going, "Wait, why didn't you
This is like mass hysteria with food shops is, oh, steel ban
me. Steel man meal. Steel man me. Try to steal me. It's Bro,
you're not even making
I disagree with you. Why do you need to use OCR or whatever?
Um,
you don't have to. You could just use OCR and then compare the
two strings across two different things. Yeah, it'd be totally
fine. That's all. But yeah, it's like I don't understand why
the expert on their side would have to steel menu or even speculate
on why these things are different.
But he says that this is evidence of me. Oh, sir queefs a lot.
Are you the same guy that emailed me? I just didn't put this
out because I don't know if it was relevant or not, but somebody
said Google and being crawlers follow robots.txt file. You can
see if search crawlers would index the P. Ah, you heard about
this here first. Okay.
That's me, by the way. That that person probably just watched
my stream when I explained it to them. Aren't I a nice guy that
I just analyze this stuff and I I do actually steal, man. I do
actually say, "Hey, look, here's like a good argument for the
other side." >> With sensitive dads, lol. Um, I had a um,
somebody emailed me about this and showed that you can actually
go through all of the file information on um, Discord media files
and you can see that they have that like it's like no dash robots
or something for
Yeah, but that's literally what they allege after 2022
or sorry after 2023. It's like December 2023 they fix that, right?
And they they disallow those URLs from being crawled.
How does he not know?
How did how did the person emailing him not know >> not
crawling but like I wouldn't include because I feel like you
could probably ignore that if you wanted to. I don't but maybe
you say they follow it. But um I don't know. I just didn't include
that. But >> you can ignore that but no actual reputable
web crawler does. >> I don't even need that argument because
it's obvious that they're not indexing every single private media
file. This is ridiculous, right?
Um so anyway, he says, "Wait, but they do index they did have
indexing open for that. If you posted that thing somewhere, it
would get indexed."
That's the whole That's the whole argument they were making and
then they fixed it. >> There is more evidence of tampering.
The two Google Drive links that Banell purportedly sent to both
Abby and Peach in the two chat threads are actually not the same
link. The highlighted links below are from ECF132-7
and the non-highlighted links are from ECF32-6.
The highlighted URL has da31
lowercase L and the
uh sorry two legs. He is arguing that right now, right? So, the
incompetence here would be his lawyers, but um somebody was incompetent
in handling this, but it is the the only thing they're pointing
out is that there's a discrepancy there. There's a discrepancy
here that's not being tracked. They didn't even notice it because
they don't care about preserving evidence. The bottom one has
ZHR31
number one. Also, the highlighted URL ends in WBT/view and the
bottom one ends in WBV view, right? So, like what? So, are you
saying that I intentionally edited these in a place where a scanner
would up like what is the argument? The highlighted link begins
with 1K and the other one comes from this and believe the I hold
on
that's not that's not the argument which was relied on by defendant
in his motion to dismiss for his assertion that he that his preserved
communication logs with ABMC conclusively established that he
never transmitted the video to her at any time is not reliable
evidence because it appears to have been tampered with as in
there is no immutable record of these logs and even within his
own testimony these logs have been mutated.
Yes, that's that is the argument. That is a totally fine argument
to make. Now, if you want to submit an an affidavit from Andrew
Breler's law firm saying, "Hey, this guy this guy totally this
up. Actually, we totally this guy, right?" Cuz he's going to
say, I believe he says that it's the law firm handing it off
that that screwed this up. If he wants to say that, then they
should have to produce like an affidavit from that side saying,
"No, no, no, no. It was actually up in this way." Right. And
also, did they make that argument in court? Maybe they did. Hold
on. Maybe I I would be very interested to see if they made that
argument in their reply. Like this wasn't actually a problem
with the with our evidence. It was theirs. Hold on.
Hold on. Hi Farms. So past copy pasting verbatim this stuff.
So they say that he copy pasted it verbatim without even attempting
to retracting from a different thing. So they don't even they
don't even allege this in court. Why don't they allege this in
court? Because wouldn't that wouldn't that say like wouldn't
that help them say, "Oh, Destiny's like um Destiny's records
of this are actually like good." It sounds like he is claiming
Pixie's lawyers handing them off caused it.
It they're not in Pixie's lawyer's filings. They're in Destiny's
filings. Why would Why would Destiny have submitted his stuff
through Pixie's lawyers? Huh? Wait, what? This can't possibly
be done, right? You can't possibly rely on this. That's incontention.
What's in contention? I What's Sorry,
there's nothing I unless I'm missing it. What's in what's in
contention here? Hold on. Let's go down. Oh, wait, wait, wait,
wait, wait, wait, wait. I think it's uh
been repeatedly rejected by the court and paying your declaration
should be stricken. So, let's see. They've already they've never
had their motion. They've never filed a motion for spoliation.
So, it hasn't been rejected by the court. Um the court has said
if you're concerned about spilation, file a motion. They didn't
do so.
Uh the the plaintiff believes expert testimony requires
conclusively
accusing tampering accusing Benell of tampering with evidence.
Mr. Pñena plagiarized his sworn testimony. DD copypasted portions
of his expert opinion directly from a third party post on Kiwi
Farms
verbatim from this post. Worse while well while Mr. Pena attempted
to conceal his actions by removing. So then they're saying that
he attempted to hide this two days ago. He amended
he amended. So they're not making whatever excuse Destiny has,
right? Whatever excuse Destiny has here about Pixie's lawyers
having it or, you know, somebody scanning this and [__]
it up. Whatever excuse he has here isn't even filed in the court
case. Why is it not filed in the court case?
Because I believe the the expert is saying, "Hey, this like differentiation,
this is up. This is like really up that it's not just the logs
being transmitted perfectly. Something's really
footnote 3." Oh, is it in here? Oh, good. Because I I would say
they need an affidavit from Andrew's law firm saying this much,
right? Hold on. Why can't I am I It's not going to pop up, is
it? I'll just go. Like there's claim that the Google Drive link
sent to ABMC and Peach do not match is incorrect. The single
character difference, a lowercase L instead of the number one
is a routine artifact of text to PDF conversion required for
ECF filing. Not evidence of any substantive discrepancy. Plaintiff's
purported expert should know better. Um, wait,
I assume you have like a burden to remain correct with these
things, right? I assume you can't just file things and go, "Well,
uh, scanning it, we it up."
>> Also, I'll just point out now, you could tell me if
this is lawyering too close to the sun, latigious gamer, but
are they saying that that's what happened or are they saying
that this is a routine?
Would this be like um would this be considered an admission that
you did scan this stuff and [__] it up
or because it sounds like they're saying that this is a routine
artifact without saying that they did it.
>> Am I crazy?
They're not saying that's what happened. They're just saying
it's a routine artifact of converting to PDF, which I actually
don't even know if that's like 100% true. Routine artifact of
text to PDF conversion.
Uh, I would imagine for court cases you would have things that
could convert text to PDF without it up at all. Yeah, I think
they should have to submit a declaration that they screwed this
up or something screwed this up submitting it, right? Yeah, they're
they're literally not saying that's what happened.
They're just saying that could happen. Hypothetically that could
have happened. Wait, did are you saying that that happened or
are you saying hypothetically that could have happened? That's
a very interesting way to mislead the court possibly. No. It's
routine to get links wrong in filings and if you don't agree,
you're unhinged apparently. I think I think you're So the concern
is documents produced for the court by Destiny
have the issue where there's no hash uh giving like a what do
you call it? There's no hash submitted for any of these files.
Therefore, they could submit evidence and go oopsie. They can't
like recheck against themselves. I think this response purposefully
avoided responding to any of the experts testimony. In other
words, they don't think they need to fix it at this time. they
need to fix it this time. I think I think Destiny's like response
here is very interesting how he's basically saying like oh the
>> why are they why are they coming to the murder for murderer
for the record when the murderer like is on the record having
disturbed the crime scene. Uh hash isn't silly little bits it's
not silly. It literally prevents things from being up um accidentally,
right? Which they just did. That's the That's the point they're
making is like, "Oh, you've just things up and you're saying
it's accidental, but if you had hashes, you could have just checked
these these things against each other, right? In fact, they could
have just done it by checking the text,
but because there are no hashes, there is no like record of when
they were archived and stuff."
Um, the expert didn't it up in the filings. Um, the argument
would be that Destiny's law firm would have [__]
it up in their filings. Maybe. Uh, you don't need a hash for
text. You don't need a hash for text, which is why I said in
this case, you could just compare the text. But a hash for some
of this stuff, I assume would like prevent you from screwing
it up, right? Like
you accidentally delete something and you go, "Oh, the hash is
off. Let me fix that." Uh, you know, if they asked me to give
that Well, I think he would, Zani. I think he would. I don't
think it'd be a problem. Yeah, you could just compare the the
text. Although there there's like metadata to the text that it
would be nice to have a hash for, right? We have a multiffield
like a col or what do you call it? like a row in a document.
Shouldn't you have I mean, you should have the original copies.
Um, it would be funny for them to say, could you submit the copies
um that you have as evidence outside of a PDF? Could you could
you submit what was submitted to you to show this? I think that
would be interesting. No, that'd be very interesting. Like, could
you show us that like evidence that this was um the OCR stuff
that [__] it up possibly or like what happened? I'm
assuming it like it is OCR stuff almost certainly, but is it
the court's OCR stuff or did Desty do that for some reason? That
would be the
I kind of do assume it's the law firm
right? Like that would make the most sense is if it was the law
firm,
Oh, wait, wait, wait.
>> There actually this is a really important question to
ask, isn't it? Because the only way it would be a problem for
OCR on Destiny's end is if he didn't have logs of some stuff
he'd sent Abby because things had been deleted and then he like
realized that
and so he had screenshots but not logs and he took like a screenshot
of the drive link maybe.
I kind of assume he's just got all the logs though. Seems like
a guy who collects all that stuff.
>> we go back to the video document production and his
evidence submitted in support of his motion to dismiss. The first
instance relates to an excerpt of Discord messages from defend.
>> Oh, this is also the wrong video.
>> 1K or L.
Thus, the above evidence which was relied on by defendant in
his motion to dismiss his assertion that his preserved communication
with ABMC conclusively established that he never transmitted
the video to her at any time is not reliable evidence because
it appears to have been tampered with. Now, okay, so I said before,
right? I have a lot of money, so I can afford to fight this stuff.
You know, just find my way too. >> Uh, I would agree that
this seems most likely Panda Rider, but I'm saying there's an
outside chance that for some reason Destiny doesn't have the
logs he should have and is using like a screenshot to recreate
like the the
right? There's like an outside chance. I don't believe it's likely.
I think it's like 2%.
>> 2% chance, but I just I think it would be funny to see
if that were the case. Uh, hold on. Let's Let's go. >> Demonetization,
everything. The egregious thing, the really really really disgusting
thing is
>> the really really really disgusting thing. Oh no. >> It's
got to be that he like totally made some up. He totally got some
wrong. >> Wait, what was I just making sure?
Is this disgusting piece of [__]
Didn't write any of this. disgusting. >> Remember how I
keep saying they steal arguments from Kiwi farms? Okay, so he
he wrote the link out for this here,
but this idiot I'm at courter.com.
Okay, so this is what is publicly uploaded. This [__]
didn't change this to an actual link and he accidentally left
his source material here, which is a
>> Wait, so he linked to his source material? By the way,
these are just the URLs, which is very funny, right?
>> Uh, it's Yeah, it's all very funny. This
is the argument incorrect. >> Link to an image hosted on
Kiwi Farms.
Now, seeing this, obviously, >> obviously seeing that it's
from a Kiwi Farms post, >> that means
>> I tried to um scroll around to see if I could find Okay.
Well, I wonder if he actually like got these AR. >> Setting
rules of civil procedure 42069.
Okay. Link to Kiwi Farms automatically automatically results
in a disbarment for the lawyers and
a forfeite of the case. Okay.
When did he start doing all this gay moral loading? Um, the same
time everybody has ever used gay moral loading against him in
a debate. When he started not having like material factual ground
to stand upon, right? As soon as he lost his like actual factual
ground to stand upon. As soon as he lost the ability to make
the best arguments,
well, now he has to do all the moral loading that everybody else
had to do that he would constantly point out is like gross to
him >> arguments from the thread. this piece of [__]
So like
I can literally control C this whole including the punctuation
and everything. He literally ripped this line for line from one
of my biggest fans code cave.
both of the examples that he took here, right? highly link
I isn't it like embarrassing
it isn't it like super embarrassing for an actual law firm to
argue that this is
>> like they're taking like just an immutable fact and
the guy copyping like an immutable fact >> and they're
saying that that's
>> I don't right I can copy paste this whole chunk here
the whole thing he ripped Both of these examples, word from word,
punctuation and everything, he just copy pasted them from Kiwi
Farms. When you pay an expert witness,
your honor, your honor,
we're ruling that
we're we're ruling that stealing memes from your chat, from your
community,
that's uh that's plagiarism. Okay? You copy those memes from
your community, you post them for yourself, for your enrichment,
you that that is plagiarism. Your entire social media page, okay,
your entire Twitter feed is now disbarred. Okay, it's disallowed.
It is thrown out. You have to delete it. It's over. You're paying
money for somebody with expertise to establish some fact to the
court, to the judge or the jury to establish some fact that they
can.
>> Okay. So, all we need from Destiny here is for him to
show us what fact is incorrect about the portions copied from
Kiwi Farms, right? So he's arguing that you're paying this person
for their expertise to get things correct. So in if in his expertise
these things are correct.
Uh why would he have to cite this? Why would he have to do this?
Well, like if it's all correct, what is the problem?
Um well, I I think you your honor, I'm like to file a motion
to label this evidence as disgusting and unhinged
and comment on because they're expertise in an area. Why the
[__] are these guys paying an expert witness
to copy paste from Kiwi Farms? How can you confidently like
I don't do anything with filing down here, but like if I had
a prior court case involving this dude, you better believe I
would attack all of this guy's expert witness testimony. I don't
think I would trust this for anything. How the [__]
are you copy pasting whole parts of your argument from a Kiwi
Farms post? And you can see this is exactly where he got the
argument. I feel like this would discredit you from like I just
that's just insane. >> Why is he gonna say why or is he
just going to keep calling it insane and
Like he's unfortunately become a meme of himself. This is so
crazy. This is This is unhinged. This is so crazy.
Like what? Could you just point out what's wrong? Insane to me.
How could you do that?
This is He's supposed to be an expert witness,
>> dude. No way. Hold on. >> I feel like this would
discredit you from like I just That's just insane to me. How
could you do that?
>> This is He's supposed to be an expert witness.
Unless he wants to come out and say, "Well, I am Code Cave and
that's why I I actually am that guy." So, it's I'm actually just
copying for myself.
>> But I'm just It's funny that like
dude I
And you'd think it would be like embarrassing to uh to throw
these arguments out. You think he would be embarrassed. It's
like so obvious.
Uh if you could show this to him, okay, if you could somehow
obiscate his face, get in a time machine and show this to him
in 2022, I think he would lose his mind on the person trying
to make these arguments. It would be very funny to watch. But
you can also see that he tried he tried to intentionally hide
that he was copying from Kiwi Farms because when you look at
the both of these images here are images hosted on Kiwi Farms.
He remembered to transcribe this first link. He transcribed the
first link to hide where he was stealing his
testimony from. Like
>> I is this not
>> to me I just feel like this is evidence that he didn't
care that he didn't think it was wrong so he didn't have any
problem with showing it. >> Where have Where in any other
place have they been like ashamed or not wanting to use Kiwi
Farms? Yeah, Laguna is on the move again. I think I feel like
um I feel like the Code Cape guy probably does that just to with
us today. He forgot to transcribe the second link and he left
in the copied pictures for both. Right. You see this here? So,
on this first one, he managed to cover his tracks, but on the
second one, he up and he left the original link to the expert
witness, by the way. And remember this, I'm not showing you this
from an email. I'm not showing you this from like uh, you know,
some This is a public court filing that's available on Court
Lindister. If you've got a Pacer account, you can look this up.
This is like, you know, item 139, attachment one on the docket.
It's just insane to me. Uh, I should have I should have actually
gone and looked at any of the chat to see if um if anybody's
pointing out that
>> just just to see if anybody's pointing out the the clear
fallacy here, like the the clear and obvious problem with his
finally, I note the following. Ball also keep this is a form
that constantly talks about being
and calls me.
>> Okay. Did he wait? Hold on.
One. Okay. Two things need to happen here now. Okay. If the forum
sorry if the expert copy pasted a line saying Destiny is a
loser
then one I will try to high-five that guy at some point and two
then I think you could probably start dismissing his testimony.
I think that's fair. If he if he copy pasted that Desi is a loser
into these documents into his expert testimony that's that's
kind of [__] up from a legal perspective and I think
Destiny's is totally correct that this should be dismissed but
if he didn't if he didn't copy paste some like some I I'll give
it to you that's probably unhinged. Okay. If he didn't if he
didn't copy paste some like deranged commentary then I don't
understand what the problem is. If you copy pasted like just
atomically correct facts that can't be changed, then what's the
problem? Else has horrible names and docs and harasses people,
sends threats like all the fact that she's just wait and harass
people. Oh my god, they sound evil. It's like I just hate the
fact that she's just like frolicking around doing whatever relevant
she's doing with her life.
This is like a perfect look into Desie's like psyche. the person
whose material he is the source of for the entire internet against
their will. Uh in his head, the thing that makes him more angry
than any other thought is the idea that she might one day be
happy again. That's that's like the most egregious idea in her
head is that these people who were willing to stand up for themselves
that they might be happy. This is like the worst idea. Like this
is where we talk about him being like sort of cold-blooded like
a lizard person, not really human in any >> Life right
now. I don't even know if she follows any record case anymore
if she
just like doing whatever, you know. Meanwhile, I have to like
respond to all of these things. It's incredibly timeconuming.
My career is basically on hold until this like gets figured out
because I don't expect anybody to read through all these filings.
But it's just like a huge it's just like a huge joke to to her
and all these people and it's wasting the court's time. And supposedly,
you know, this is a chick who wants to go to school and be a
lawsuit and a like, okay, whatever. >> I don't think it's
wasting the I mean, listen, we'll see. possibly this entire thing
gets dismissed right now,
right? If the whole thing gets dismissed, then yeah, I guess
they might have been wasting the court's time,
right? I think you you have to agree to that. Like if it gets
dismissed, then
>> I mean, it depends. It's like I think they probably
had some expectation that they were going to uh find things that
some of their witnesses would come forward for them. So, I don't
think they were like initially wasting the court's time. Maybe
you could argue like after a certain point when they hadn't established
um maybe if they, you know, had some reason to doubt Abby or
something, you could argue it. I don't know. I'm like trying
to be fair, but realistically, I think I think the Abby testimony
is like kind of insanely compelling to me. Like this person predicted
the existence of videos that we wouldn't learn about until a
year later
and didn't miss didn't just make up a bunch of names. They just
got it totally correct.
>> Oh, let's see here.
>> Ry, I do wonder. It's kind of funny. Nah, she was just
drunk. Wait, what are you talking about?
>> Does he unironically believe that Pixie is having a
fun time doing all this or is he playing it up? He sounds so
inhuman. I think occasionally she posts like a happy picture
to social media and that probably like makes him see, makes him
like rage.
>> I'm guessing. I'm guessing that's what it is.
>> I love his new word frolicking. Yeah.
>> Well, Destin, I think the issue is is they thought they
had somebody here, right, who was like validating the Cardi claim.
Uh, yeah, but I I just don't think they they did. I think they
ended up not having somebody who would validate the Cardi claim.
Um, finally, I note the following. Bunell states that the original
file name of the video as revealed by solitary leaks is not the
same as either the file names that he sent to ABMC. That proves
that he never sent the video to ABMC. But Bunell is comparing
apples to oranges because the two file names in ECF 1326 that
he purportedly sent to ABMC at on November 3rd, 2023 are not
files names. They're Google Drive URLs which merely point to
unknown file names. Um he's bringing this up. I don't try to
that's not the argument that I make though. The argument I make
is that the exact same Google Drive link is sent to two different
people and one of those people proves through their messages
with me that the it is of them and not of the defendant or not
of the plaintiff. That's the whole point of this. So he either
didn't read it, misread it or whatever. Under penalty of perjury,
I declare that I've read the forgoing document and the fact are
true to the best of my knowledge and belief. And then yeah, now
that Rose was served, does she have to testify? I don't know
if the court I think they're basically trying to get a subpoena,
right? Like they served her. Oh no, I don't think they have to.
I think I actually think that um Oh man,
sorry. I just saw a funny I just I just got linked like two very
funny clips.
Um and I totally lost what I was say. Holy [__] Hold
on. Uh what was I what was I just saying? Sorry. Riyle just blew
my mind with these two clips and I'm I'm like laughing to myself.
If the if the the quotes he gave me are correct. I totally lost
my train of thought. That's my bad. That's my ADHD coming out,
guys. My bad. My bad.
Oh, Rose served. Right, right, right.
um I think Rose was named as a person of interest by one of the
parties. I think probably Destiny. So, I think you do have the
ability to subpoena them for a civil case. I think,
right, like that's somebody who's listed with relevant per like
relevant evidence to the case. Um we'd have to go look because
both sides I think filed like filed like lists of people with
knowledge of the case or something, right? so that the other
side could
Was Rose actually served? Does that mean she's forced to join
and testify? Uh, she was actually served. I don't know if she's
forced to testify. I don't know if they can compel that testimony.
She's identified. I just don't know what the ability is for a
federal judge to compel like a person of interest to testify
in a court case.
I don't know. Like, she could be subpoenaed, but I don't know
if the court has the ability, like if she's in a different state,
could the judge force her to? And then that's really just to
resolve the discrepancy of like October or April. So, like, is
the judge going to decide that that's like that's known? I don't
know. Like, the judge could just say, "No, we're pretty convinced
that it's April now." Right? And they could say, "Oh, actually,
I don't
I don't actually
uh what would you call it?" They could say like, "Yeah, I don't
actually care to get this testimony anymore."
But I think they're allowed to they're allowed to subpoena her
for documents or for testimony, though, because she's listed
as listed as a person of interest in the in the whole thing.
I just don't know if it'll be enforced. why bring Rose in when
we already know. So basically JT docar the testimony from Destiny's
side is like well it's from a European time zone or something.
Um that's why the date stamps are this way but they know Rose
isn't from a European time stamp or time zone. And so they're
saying basically like we can't say for sure which way the time
stamps go. We don't have access to like uh third party Discord
logs or anything like that. So
we need to like the poster directly and get her testimony on
when these logs are from. Yeah. I think I think it's the 1004
stuff. Yep. Yep. Yep. Yep. Yep. Yep. Yep.
Why does it matter that he got the info in Kiwi Farms? That must
be the best place to get information because I'm obsessed there.
Why does it matter? Because he's testifying to the veracity of
my evidence as an expert witness. If plaintiff wants to state,
we read on Kiwi Farms that they said this, then state that. But
you can't pay an expert witness to give your own testimony. That's
not how that works. Like, let's say that I say I know that plaintiff
has been using psychological warfare against me and is using
actual black magic spells to attack me. And then let's say I
pay an exponent like can you just like write this in there say
that you're like a a CIA expert and then just like write what
I'm telling you. You can't do that. That's not the point of a
expert witness. So he perjured himself. I don't know if it counts
as perjury. I would the expert witness just said you didn't maintain
like any chain of custody on this. And we can tell that because
obviously things have been edited.
I I don't see where that would be perjury or even wrong. He's
saying you didn't follow general digital forensics procedures.
That's true. He's saying it's evident that you don't have like
a solid claim to have any chain of custody over this stuff because
you produced no you didn't do any of the procedures they normally
do. Okay. And like we could see that this is the case because
you've totally failed to make sure that the evidence you're producing
to the court corresponds with other evidence you produce to the
court. There's like clearly mutations to the data that are happening
and you're not even tracking
Uh, a sub may command a person to attend a trial hearing or dis
or deposition only within 100 miles of where the person resides,
is employed, or regularly transacts business in person per rule
45. Okay. So, latigious gamer, I I've got to believe that if
you would go set up close to them that you wouldn't be forced
to like you could go set up the deposition where they are, right?
So, if they were willing to serve um like serve her, then I think
they could go to wherever she is and depose her, right? If they
wanted to.
I'm guessing if it's just a matter of convenience say well I
can't say I would say because I don't know what counts for now
but yeah but anyway this is yeah that was their expert witness
thing I just spent so much time going over all this and like
writing up a huge for this just so unbelievable
um not only that but also as like a quick as a quick lols
um this was filed two days ago he filed an amendment saying it's
come to my attention that in paragraph 17 and 18 in my October
3rd, 2025 declaration. I made a conclusion of tampering based
on defendants's incomplete and faulty document production. These
documents produced,
>> by the way, this is just this is just for the one thing
where he didn't know about the the grouping or he failed to see
the grouping correctly. This is just his one thing and he amended
it before there was any opposition or before anybody evaluated
it. So, I don't even understand why that would be a problem actually.
So, he admits here that oh actually I was wrong about the whole
Discord timestamp thing. Imagine an expert witness amending their
statements like three days later. But >> wait, somebody
So he's basically this is an expert in digital forensics, right?
Like um producing evidence for court cases. He might not have
produced a lot of evidence from Discord. That could be true.
He would still be an expert in digital forensics.
It doesn't have to produce things from >> Actually, this
is how Discord messages work. [__] Is your writing
going to be an outline for your lawyer? Yeah, I don't I don't
understand why that would even be like a problem that the testimony
would have gone in. Yeah, he corrected his mistake. I Dude,
this guy's incompetent. He s he cited Kiwi Farms. He plagiarized
from Kiwi Farms and you should strike his whole testimony because
he didn't file an amendment in a timely fashion. It's like, wait,
when did he file the amendment?
Like, how how far away was this? Like 4 days, 5 days? 3 days
later? It was filed on Friday and they filed the amendment on
Monday. So it's the next day. Oh. So like
so literally the next business day the amend they filed an amendment
for the expert testimony and they're sitting here so out about
the thing he got wrong and was like oh I double checked this
and oh I have to this up. >> No. All I when I write up
stuff, it's just to like explain to them like this is what he's
saying and then this is why it doesn't apply here and then here's
like my evidence to showcase that and then it's up to them for
how to format that in a legal brief or how to format that or
if they need to bring in somebody else or whatever. Are we allowed
to respond to the response? I believe I believe we get one response
to this response and then it goes to the and then the judge has
to decide. But anyway,
okay. So, that was their expert witness testimony that they have
as part of their >> Wow. Hold on. I've got uh I might have
one more time stamp here. Let me check for the one more time
stamp and then from there I'll move to
uh oh I think I watched this one already. I think we watched
more just stole it all came from any >> Yeah, we we got
this whole thing already. Okay, we got that whole thing now.
Uh I hesitate to watch like food shop stuff very often. She's
a total [__] loser. But apparently this is pretty
funny. Okay.
Um, I just want to see I want to listen to this. Okay, >> cuz
people keep saying this. >> People keep saying this thing.
It's like, okay, well, Destiny might have done a bad thing, but
she did a bad thing, too. >> No, that means that nobody
did a bad thing. That like people say two wrongs don't make a
right, but in some circumstances, they he's talking about legally
wise. I don't actually agree with this. I just want to clarify.
I don't actually agree with this. Okay.
And it's also incorrect legally. And it is basically relying
on his assertion that Pixie is a liar when she has evidence that
she didn't lie about having the consent to send it to her
>> I think I think this is a solid point that I actually
disagree. >> Sorry. What? Transmit to that she had consent
to transmit to her boyfriend.
Because at the end of the day, we're looking at Destiny's behavior,
right? Like we're not we don't care all that much about Pixie,
right? Except in the context of like legal, right? Like for me
at the very least I'm looking about what Destiny
>> Oh, she doesn't really care about Pixie. I guess listen,
she doesn't really care about Pixie. She's like talking about
how good or bad Destiny is, guys. She doesn't she doesn't like
she doesn't hate Pixie >> specifically has done. Um even
if the other person has done something bad, that kind of lessens
Destiny's like whatever actions. I've always said this, by the
way. Like I've always said that I don't agree with all the actions
and everything that has happened within Destiny's perspective.
I'm pretty sure the person I agree with the most is Loner Box's
perspective, not Destiny's perspective. The reason, >> oh,
Loner Box, who thinks Pixie is like a pure victim here, and Destiny
is clearly lying about it and trying to defame her for no reason,
like completely maliciously. And that Destiny has also tried
to malign or or defame Loner Box completely maliciously, right?
Where Destiny like tries to imply pretty consistently in the
months after the Pixie allegations that Lonerbox is a like totally
leaning into the Hassan thing. totally leaning into it first
chat. Yeah, I remember that. Okay, but listen. She said she agrees
with Loner Box. So, hold on. That was a day ago. I'm guessing
that's within the past little while. Let's see what she has to
say about Pixie now. >> Issued by one core, too. So, by
the way, I just want to say if anyone is still like trying to
defend Pixie in the sense that she shouldn't be doxed.
I actually think that her like all of her actions so far >> 100%
justifies her doxing. I truly believe so. Like wow, that's pretty
cool to just announce on a on a stream. That's very interesting.
The person who Destiny goes on the stream of constantly just
calling for that. Okay. >> I think I'm not advocating for
anyone to do it. I'm not going to do it myself. Okay. But I'm
just saying there >> Oh, listen. I'm not I'm not saying
you guys should go and kill Peter Griffin from Family Guy, okay?
But I do think that he should totally be killed. Like, I totally
advocate for his death, for his By the way, this is a joke with
a fictional character. So, just in case anybody from support
looks at this is a meme, right? I totally support you guys. Peter
Griffin from Family Guy, but like I'm not advocating for someone
to do it. Like I I totally support the idea that he'd be murdered
violently, but like
but like you know you know she did name drop like four people
in a lawsuit while trying to hide.
Uh wait, she names Oh Jesus. Um wait, how can you virtue signal
about how this person deserves to be doxed when they're when
the person who's making that virtue signal is themselves like
doxing? Jesus.
Jesus Christ.
Anyway,
wait. What did food shops just imply? That Pixie deserves to
be doxed
for her actions.
I guess. I guess.
I don't know why, by the way, why those couldn't have been filed
um redacted. That's just weird. Again, um just so we're clear,
the people who do the redactions, the people who who go over
these documents are her legal team,
I just say that like you don't know what she's telling them to
put in versus what the legal team's putting in. Yeah. It's it's
like you're you're blaming her for the legal team. I don't know.
Yeah.
I just thought that was funny that food job says, "Oh, I agree
most with Lonerbox." When I believe she totally disagreed with
Loner Box's hypothetical, right, on the situation, but she's
like, I guess trying to like distance from Destiny in some way
and is like, "Oh, I actually agree most with Loner Box." and
then argues for Pixie to be doxed.
Okay, that's uh
very cool, very neat, very interesting. Oh, wait. Did I not finish
the previous clip? Hold on. I must have
ri wants me to watch this whole thing. Hold on.
>> Cuz people keep saying that specifically has done's
perspective. The reason why I defend Destiny is because he deserves
the representation. He deserves the good faith arguments. But
the thing is is um like if I if >> they don't argue in
good faith at all, which is why they'll never debate this, which
is why they'll never ever come and have a contentious conversation
ever.
Why they run constantly, right? They refuse to have a contentious
conversation on any of this.
I don't if let's just say I was in an environment where where
there are legitimately a lot of people arguing for destiny to
the point where I'm not needed. Okay? If I'm not needed, okay,
if I'm not needed, then I'm probably going to be aligning myself
more with a critic. Absolutely. Yeah. But like the only She's
literally arguing for defensive doxic of people like two months
ago. >> Reason why like I'm doing this because I just believe
that even as a critic, you know, I believe that Destiny deserves
>> Oh, I believe I imagine someone in chat told them litter
box has a good take and that's what le led to this absurdity.
>> Yeah. I don't I don't know. some good faith public representation
because he has none right now, you know, that's it.
>> uh, he's got an audience that's 10 to 100 times the
size of anybody who's criticizing him. >> I feel like that's
representation. Maybe not. Maybe not.
I just think about the things that are being said, right? Like,
hey, I actually think this person's in the wrong. I think they're
in the wrong. I think they're actually kind of gross, to be honest
with you. and I'm just taking their side because I know that
there aren't a lot of influencers doing that and you know I I
kind of ignore my own opinion and I do it because not a lot of
influencers are on her are on his side. It's like oh well like
why would somebody do that? Wouldn't it matter? Wouldn't the
merits matter? It's like well the merits would matter. You cared
about principles cared about money. Well
I could see why you do it in that case. I can see why you go
and and do the steel manning.
That's very interesting. Very, very neat. I'm sure Lonabox appreciates
um food shops calling for, you know, Pixie deserves to be docks.
Just just going on her stream. Pixie totally deserves to be docked.
I'm not saying somebody should do it,
but you know, I'm just saying it deserves she deserves it. Okay,
cool.
Nice.
All right. Very neat. Oh, did I not finish your clip again? Because
people keep
a lot of people arguing for Destiny to the point where I'm not
needed. Okay. If I'm not needed, okay, if I'm not needed, then
I'm probably going to need to align myself more with a critic.
Absolutely. Yeah. But like the only reason why I like a video
is because I just believe that even as a critic, you know, I
believe that Destiny deserves like some good faith public representation
because he has none right now, you know? That's it. Um, yeah.
Reminder that this person gets hosted/bedded over Darius. Funny.
Uh, yeah. This person Darius, listen, for all Darius's, I think
Darius doesn't want to uh Darius doesn't want to just lie, right?
I don't believe so. He wants to have some of like of his own
he wants some of his own like career outside of that. Although,
who knows? I think things are kind of looking more bleak. So,
all right. All right. What are we doing next? What are we doing
next, guys? I think we're we're pretty much done with this. I
don't know if there's anything else that was interesting here.
>> Darius will lie. Um,
>> probably. Yeah, I'm probably giving Darius way too much
charity.